Now let's take another sort of toy example, of two quantities that we could very
easily relate to one another, with an equation, where one of the quantities
depends on the other quantity. And think about the relationship between those
two variables a little bit more. So let's say that we have a candy machine, for
which there is a set price for candy. So if I put one kind of coin in the candy
machine, it gives me a certain amount of candy. So in this case the input, is
the amount of money that you put into the candy machine. Just like for Athena,
with her soda machine the input was the money that she put into the soda
machine. And the output here, is the amount of candy that comes out of the
machine, just like the number of sodas was the output for Athena earlier. So
which of these two statements do you think makes the most sense? For a given
amount of money put in, there's more than one possibility for the amount of
candy that the candy will dispense. Or for a given amount of money put in, there
is at most one possibility for the amount of candy that the machine will
dispense. Think about how this machine works, and how you think that input and
output should be related to each other.